o la suerte esa ola qué puedo hacer por
usted bueno es que tengo un problema
mañana tendré una fiesta y quisiera
tener 18 manos y sólo tengo 10 okey
déjeme ver si puedo contarlos
uno dos tres cuatro cinco seis siete
ocho nueve diez si tiene razón sólo
tiene diez
y exactamente
eso fue lo que te dije pero cuántos
monos más necesito para tener 18
bueno tal vez nuestros amigos que están
viendo pueden ayudar cuantos monos
necesita la reina para llegar a 18 ahora
tiene 10 cuantos necesita para tener 18
asumo que nuestros amigos ya lo
intentaron así que vamos a pensar en
esto juntos cuantos monos se necesitan
para llegar a 18 si ponemos uno más
ahora tenemos 11 llegamos a 11 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 9 10 y 11 si ponemos otro vamos a
tener 12
12 con una más
vamos a llegar a 13 y vamos a seguir
haciendo esto
14 ponemos otro y ahora tenemos 15 con
este otro tenemos 16
16 y luego con otro más
tenemos 17 y ponemos otro y tenemos 18
18 monos y lo que queremos es llegar a
18 entonces cuando sumamos ok antes
teníamos 10 todos estos que están aquí
arriba son 10 monos aquí en este cuadro
tenemos 10 monos voy a escribir 10 aquí
de este lado y sumamos 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
sumamos 8 monos y escribo este 8 por acá
sumamos 8 monos a estos 10 que teníamos
antes para llegar a 18
otra manera de pensar en esto es 18 es
lo mismo que 10 10 más
8 18 es igual a 10 más 8
y ahora podré
la cantidad apropiada de monos para mi
fiesta gracias a usted siempre es un
placer ayudar la reina y veo que
encontramos un patrón interesante en
esto que tenemos aquí 18 es igual a 10
más 8 si pensamos en el número 10
podemos ver que 10 es igual a una decena
este un amarillo es 10 es una decena más
0 unidades
el número 11 es igual a una decena este
1 representa una decena y este 1
representa una unidad así que es igual a
10 más 1
y podríamos continuar escribiendo este
patrón con otros números animo a los
amigos que nos están escuchando a que
traten de hacerlo con los números que
siguen hasta el 19 y que lo escriban
como lo tenemos aquí fíjense en el
número 18 este 1 representa una decena y
este 8 representa 8 unidades
así que si empezamos con 10 cuantos
tenemos que sumar para llegar a 18 bueno
pues este 1 que tenemos aquí representa
10 así que tenemos que sumar 8 unidades
10 + 8 es igual a 18
y está listo
de matemáticas de nada reina